I want to show you this clip this is
from Joe Rogan's show it's a UFC fighter
he's a major fighter his name is Sean
Strickland and they start talking about
how corporations actually are the ones
that are now anti-america
it's like this Unholy Alliance that
corporations are doing to America they
want women working they want lower wages
and they want more consumerism and it's
like I don't mean it like I'm not sexist
like oh put woman back in the kitchen
you know they suck and I love you know
take off the burger we're huzzah
but but you know what I'm saying but
we're truly like in a weird time to
where like corporations are eroding
eroding values of America well they act
within their best interests in their
best interests to keep people consumers
and make sure that people just pay
attention only to stupid
or you you have Walmart in the in the in
your phone now you want to go I mean I
can't even me I'm to blame there's some
times you guys where I'm like man I'm a
little depressed I don't know I'm just
in a bad mood I'm like I'm gonna go on
Amazon let's see what the Amazon fairy
is recommending me today maybe I could
maybe I could find something they'll
give me a little serotonin boost find
some happiness in a one click yeah and
then so it's like you and then you have
like and then on top of that now we go
full circle you have two parents working
and I'm going mostly on the west coast
you have kids dude Las Vegas graduation
where it's less than 50 High School
Dropout no GED I'm not one to talk
but how do you raise how do you raise a
family a successful family when your
kids are being raised by the system
right okay so the reason I'm showing you
that clip it's not that they're saying
anything that incredible or that
brilliant but isn't it much more honest
than what you're getting out of Joy read
over at MSNBC what you're getting out of
that CBS Morning Show with what you're
getting out of the feminine transphobic
non-transphobic product bleed thing like
all of everything that is coming out of
corporate culture right now is designed
to make us dumb stupid question reality
and everything else and then there's
just like a bunch of other people be it
Dana White be it this Strickland guy
Rogan what we're trying to do here some
other people that say RFK some other
people who are just like this is all
just kind of and nonsense to
scientists like how do we fight back
against it and you have to decide what
level of involvement you're going to
have in the midst of this whole thing
and if you don't think it's going to
come for you you really have to
understand that at every you can't just
bury your head in the sand on this one
right you just can't
[Music]